Speaker 1: All right. Let's talk to some
people. Let's hear from the people. That's
really what we're here to do. You can get in
touch with me via The David Pakman Show discord,
which you really should be part of anyway. I
think we've got thirteen or fourteen thousand
members now on the discord. It's completely
free. I'm selling you nothing other than a
good time. You can go to David Pakman dotcom
slash discord. Let's go first today to Foord
from Baton Rouge, Louisiana. Forward you are on
the air. It near me, I can hear you fine, yeah.
Speaker 2: Hey, my question is, in regards
to historical statues and building names,
I think it's pretty fair to say that almost every
U.S. president in history has been a racist to
some extent. Chomsky was talking a little
bit about this the other day. We're talking
a lot about renaming buildings named after a
particularly right wing political figures because
of their racism. But this gets kind of confusing
to me because I don't understand what kind of
calculus goes into which figures are acceptable
to name buildings after, because prominent figures
that are usually OK with, like, something like
Lincoln were racist as well. So does it have more
to do with, like, social progress in the context
of the time that they live or how do we decide who
it is and is not located in buildings after?
Speaker 1: I don't think that there's any set
rule. I mean, this is what makes it so
difficult. And, you know, last week when
radical radical Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
Green said, you know, I would even oppose taking
down Hitler statues so that we can learn from
them. And it's like, have you heard of books,
Marjorie? And a bunch of German people wrote to
me and they said there are no Hitler statues to
take down. We took them all down or we prevented
them from being built because it's so clearly
over the line. I think with Lincoln, there's
a context where Lincoln, as an individual,
what was a was a racist, as you describe that
that's not a crazy thing to say by modern
standards. At the time, his views about race were
probably sort of in line with the casual racism of
many people. But he thought slavery had to be done
away with. And that's really what he's remembered
for. He's not known as someone, for example, with
like a Confederate general. Why are they notable?
They're notable because they fought a war to keep
slavery legal and maybe they had a black friend
to use some kind of stupid term that now is used.
But what they're known for, what their legacy is,
they fought a war to keep slavery legal. Abraham
Lincoln, on the other hand. And by the way,
I don't really care about statues anyway,
so I'm just kind of going through this as a
thought experiment. Abraham Lincoln, on the other
hand, was likely casually racist, as you say,
but he said we must end slavery and slavery should
not be legal. And that's sort of his legacy.
So the context of the statue is different. Is that
does that make sense? I mean, it doesn't answer
how you decide about any particular figure.
Speaker 2: Yeah, that makes a lot of sense,
it is really confusing. Like you say,
I guess. So what you're saying is just kind of
contextualize the individual and the time that
they lived in and then, like, who was driving
social progress like Lincoln was or somebody
who was against the Civil Rights Act. Yeah.
Speaker 1: And the thing is that there are
people now who love the Confederacy and whatever
who would disagree with my characterization
about a Confederate general. They would
say, no, no, no. The legacy of a Confederate
general is not fighting for slavery. It's
fighting for the constitutionally enshrined
states' rights that this country was founded
upon. And then we have an argument. Right.
So I think that it's tough because there's sort of
very obviously over the line examples like Hitler.
But then there's a lot of other ones where the
Lincoln versus Confederate isn't a good example,
but there are grayer areas for sure. My check,
my thing, by the way, my thing for it is I just I
have a hard time caring about statues. It's like
I'm worried about we got to get people health
care. Let's get people a living wage. Let's let's
let's deal with climate. So for me, it's hard to
even think super seriously about statues.
Speaker 2: That's a good point, it feels
like statues are a big focus right now because
of the culture war on the right is a really
big deal for them, of course. Well, like
Speaker 1: Noam Chomsky said during my
interview with him earlier this week,
the cultural issues are a replacement
for actually offering policy that helps people.
Speaker 2: Right. That's why they to the right
isn't like policy focus anymore. It's more about
just the culture war. Absolutely. Thank you,
David. I appreciate that. It was
a wonderful phone call. All right.
Speaker 1: All day, Ford from Baton
Rouge, beautiful, beautiful phone cal